that's Gomez the names go to pipe
welcome to the wild while I look like
[ __ ] cowboy Hitler this is great I did
not mean for that mama mama I woke up
good morning son
oka tuck your bread is gonna eat beef
lately I like you to hit him I don't
want your help him great painting
my mom has exquisite taste in art you've
got to chase a couple of Buffalo into
two small pen next to me you killed the
Buffalo you killed him poor Steve you
didn't deserve this he's better than
that I for [ __ ] sake
oh my god come back here I'll destroy
you know me brother Jay and Fanny came
out of nowhere it's gun blazing take my
cane and relieve my pain I was pretty
cool 360 noscope my brother
oh they kill they kill all the chickens
now why did you have to kill the
chickens
alright red in the Wild West how about
that and it's like that uncle just in
the Iranian to take cam I do you see it
by the stabbing Tim Timmy what happened
I tell you what happy even give a ghost
this story continues as him as a ghost
in a day another day and every day and
in the morning that's what I'm in my
uncle's body is still laying there all
right it's good it's good alright let's
head into tan it's my jam oh you got a
new so you get the lady with a shotgun
are you it wouldn't you want a rumble
alright we cool we cool we cool we go
yes yes you're sorry
no just yet I guess you're a man of
action huh I gotta say you like that man
keep dancin you doesn't all right Clint
Vil huh
just like Clint Eastwood okay I got it
took me a while ah this place it's
wonderful
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh they be
shooting at me oh my god this isn't
chance
oh [ __ ]
they got me oh god they're suede thighs
wait a minute
way too many [ __ ] that branch in
northwest of time Robert Johnson has
been a major nuisance I need his land
but he refuses to sell $850 you joking
me
you're right $150 is a joke I love you
$300 I am quite the businessman hey how
about fastest gunslinger in this town
get rekt get that money money money
oh [ __ ] what's going on gotta drive
these buffaloes report the more living
Buffalo the better ahead we're gonna
kill all of them Buffalo's but none of
them live buffs now why would you hurt
their Buffalo's [ __ ] you made me
lose my hat stop
I'm the festive gunslinger in this town
Oh
get rekt boom oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] about to
get real
ah I'll think God come on we get there
now my buffaloes I love them so dearly
[ __ ] I died
yeah one more head yes
are we getting
do do a Hitler cowboy dance whatever
know who you are know something about
the man who burned down the ranch is
small buckle and gray jacket perfectly
complements his skinny figure that is by
a [ __ ] pimp as outfit look at this
said someone with a gray jacket who's
skinny and controls an army that's all
we know so far
man right then then straight admitted
that have an itch ooh what's this is
abstain juris oh god oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this I
like my hats
sure give me some hats - oh we [ __ ]
okay hey that's how you doing cowboy
style yo when I was if we rob the bank
it seems like a really bad idea tonight
especially since we can't shoot each
other no matter what we have to predict
that yeah
oh god they're coming from behind us no
you are not taking that sir
[ __ ] sake Oh for [ __ ] sake [ __ ] off
no [ __ ] yeah walk a lonely road they
look the only road that I have ever
known I walk this empty street on the
Boulevard of broken dreams so lonely
without a family without a hope for
justice I walk these lands to find my
own road with my trusty horse what's
your name
horsey great name horse all right press
I think I need to end the episode that
really fun game I really enjoy playing
it if you wanted me to play more hit
that like button and let me know in the
comments that's all for now however
thinking about so much for watching I
had a lot of fun and as always stay
awesome brush our hair my hair my ass my
beautiful hair my face my face my hands
my ass my ass my ass my ass